you guys should be happy that Jake is
here man no matter how you feel about
him from his Disney days YouTube days
whatever his background is the point is
he's given UFC fighters that you've
watched for years take all this trauma
and not get paid like the way they
should all these complaints about
fighter pay and fire equality and all
this and then this kid comes along built
this insane Empire and he gives these
Fighters that you love the biggest
paydays they've ever gotten their lives
and you guys hate on it
you guys hate oh this is man
now this is fake these are set up but
when Woodley was fighting you guys were
all upset that he wasn't getting equal
pay when Nate Diaz was fighting and you
guys were all upset about this or that
and the the man and Dana and the UFC as
in general and the Machine they're from
over and he man that's why we like Nate
and then he finally gets his biggest
payday he kept saying this guy
well which one is it